meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren wir
gehen gleich natürlich auf die
innenpolitische Situation nach den
Landtagswahlen ein aber ich will Ihnen
mitteilen dass wir heute im Präsidium
einen Beschluss gefasst haben der sich
mit der Unterstützung für Israel befasst
wir wollen ein konsequentes Vorgehen
gegen
proalästinensische
Terrororganisationen und wir versichern
Israel unserer Solidarität
es gehört zur deutschen staatsreson für
das Existenzrecht Israels
einzutreten nicht nur wegen unserer
historischen Verantwortung sondern auch
weil Israel in der Region unser
wertepartner ist bei allen
tagespolitischen unterschieden die es
geben kann es ist eine Demokratie ein
Rechtsstaat mit
Meinungsfreiheit und aus diesem Grund
gilt Israel unsere solid ät wir haben
eine Reihe von Maßnahmen die wir jetzt
auch in die Bundesregierung tragen und
dort beraten werden um im Sinne eines
konsequenten Vorgehens gegen
proalästinensische Terrororganisation zu
wirken und um unsere Solidarität mit dem
Staat Israel und seinen Menschen zu
unterstreichen
zesur zur innenpolitischen Situation
nach den
Landtagswahlen in Bayern und Hessen
haben wir mit
Martin und Stefan zwei sehr engagierte
Spitzenkandidaten gehabt ich habe mich
selber
auch dort engagiert wie viele andere
Mitglieder unserer Parteiführung und wir
haben gesehen dass unsere Freunde in
Bayern und Hessen einen starken
Wahlkampf gemacht haben mit Themen für
die wir gemeinsam öffentlich aufgetreten
sind und für die wir geworben haben im
Ergebnis stellen wir fest dass die FDP
zweimal niederl lagen hat hinnehmen
müssen sowohl in Bayern als auch in
Hessen m in Hessen hat es nach einem
spannenden Wahlabend jetzt den
Wiedereinzug in den Landtag gegeben aber
gleichwohl ist das Wahlergebnis für uns
natürlich unbefriedigend trotz des
großen Einsatzes der Spitzenkandidaten
und der aus auch meiner Sicht
überzeugenden Themensetzung was wir
gesehen haben
ist dass ähm die Frage der
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung der
ähm
Eindämmung von Migration
einer Klima und Energiepolitik mit
Augenmaß und dem Wunsch dass der Staat
nicht weiter bürokratisiert und mit
Verboten in das Leben drängt dass das
die Menschen elektrisiert und
mobilisiert
hat das sind Themen der
FDP die aber nicht zur Wahl der FDP
geführt haben wir setzen uns auch ein
für die Stärkung der Wirtschaft wir
wollen die Einwanderung ordnen und äh
begrenzen wir setzen uns für Klimaschutz
und Energiepolitik mit Augenmaß ein und
ja wir wenden uns auch gegen die
Bürokratisierung des Lebens das sind
unsere Themen die aber bei den beiden
Wahlen zur Wahl anderer Parteien geführt
haben es handelt sich nicht um ein
Rechtsruck wie gelegentlich jetzt schon
analysiert wird aus meiner Überzeugung
jedenfalls nicht sondern die Breite
Mitte der Gesellschaft hat mit Blick auf
Wirtschaft Migration Klimaschutz und
Energie und die Frage der
gesellschaftlichen Freiheiten versus
Bürokratismus ein klares Votum abgegeben
die FDP hat davon nicht profitieren
können obwohl es unsere Themen sind weil
in dieser Konstellation der Ampel die
FDP offensichtlich ihre thematischen
Schwerpunkte für die Menschen nicht
sichtbar und glaubwürdig und motivierend
hat darstellen
können für die Koalition in Berlin
insgesamt ist der gestrige Wahlsonntag
jetzt ein
Arbeitsauftrag alle drei
Koalitionspartner haben verloren
ähm in unterschiedlicher Weise aber alle
drei haben
verloren und deshalb ist unser Auftrag
nun unser Regierungs unsere
Regierungsarbeit äh kritisch zu prüfen
ähm und das wird die Aufgabe jetzt in
den nächsten Wochen und äh in der Zeit
bis zur Halbzeit der Legislaturperiode
sein wo entsprechen wir als
Regierungskoalition in Berlin nicht den
Erwartungen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
insbesondere bei den Fragen die ja
wahlentscheidend in ä Hessen und Bayern
waren das ist der Auftrag an uns den wir
äh gemeinsam und mit großer Umsicht in
dieser für unser Land herausfordernden
Lage annehmen werden ähm wir haben
geopolitisch ein ähäh sehr
herausforderndes umfä dass jetzt durch
äh die schreckliche Situation in Israel
sich
noch einmal ähm weiter entwickelt hat
verschlechtert hat wir haben
wirtschaftlich eine große
Herausforderung Stichwort Inflation und
Rezession deshalb sind wir uns unserer
Verantwortung in dieser Situation
außerordentlich bewusst aber es ist auch
sichtbar dass die
Regierungsarbeit jetzt miteinander
kritisch reflektiert werden muss damit
wir besser den Erwartungen und Erwartung
Erwartungen der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
entsprechen so viiel von mir aus unseren
Gremien und würde jetzt den Kollegen
gern das Wort geben Bayern und Hessen
nacheinander grüß Gott und hallo auch
von meinerseits gestern war ein
schwarzer Tag für die bayerische FDP wir
hatten ein großes Ziel in Bayern wir
wollten als bayerische FDP den ersten
Wiedereinzug in das maximilianäum in den
Bayerischen Landtag seit 45 Jahren
schaffen das ist zuletzt 1978 gelungen
und mit diesem Ziel sind wir leider
gestern
gescheitert das ist bitter angesichts
eines sehr engagiert geführten
Wahlkampfes es ist auch bitter
angesichts einer parlamentarischen
Arbeit bei der sowohl politische
Mitbewerber als auch Journalisten in
Bayern konstatieren dass diese Fraktion
sehr sachorientiert sehr fleißig
gearbeitet hat das hat uns Respekt und
Anerkennung eingebracht wir haben daraus
aber es nicht vermocht für den Bürger
abzuleiten warum es auch in Zukunft eine
liberale Fraktion im Bayerischen Landtag
braucht wir haben es auch nicht vermocht
mit unseren sachpolitischen Positionen
durchzudringen
beim Wähler in diesen sehr aufgeheizten
Zeiten in dem es in einem Wahlkampf kaum
um landespolitische Themen ging und wir
haben uns auch wir haben es auch nicht
vermocht uns abzukoppeln von dem
Negativtrend den Christian Lindner
beschrieben hat die FDP in Bayern hat
kein Polster bei dem man sagen kann wenn
die FDP insgesamt mal ein 2% nachgibt
ist man immer noch sicher im Landtag
sondern wir sind 2018 mit einem
hauchdünnen Ergebnis reingekommen und es
war klar dass wir wenn wir nur leicht
nachgeben nicht mehr parlamentarisch
vertreten sein werden das ist bitter für
uns es ist bitter für mich ganz
persönlich als
Spitzenkandidat wir als FDP in Bayern
wissen aber auch mit solchen Situationen
umzugehen wir haben das in der
Vergangenheit schon öfter durchgemacht
und wir sind zuversichtlich in 5 Jahren
dann auch wieder das Comeback in den
bayerschen Landtag zu schaffen
ja auch wir in Hessen hatten einen
schwierigen Wahlkampf herausfordernden
Wahlkampf wir haben
natürlich unser Wahlziel nicht erreicht
schwarzgrüne zu beenden die CDU hat
jetzt die Wahl zwischen SPD und Grüne im
häischen Landtag die CDU ist der
Wahlgewinner wir haben Einbußen
hinnehmen müssen aber wir haben
zumindest erreicht dass wir wieder im
hässischen Landtag vertreten sind wir
haben es mal wieder spannend gemacht das
war schon mal so sogar schon zweimal mal
so und es ist in Hessen immer knapp aber
es war gestern ein grimi aber mit einem
Happy End für die FDP denn wir sind
wieder im hessischen Landtag mit rund
1000 Stimmen und überm Durst wie man so
schön sagt wir haben einen sehr
engagierten Wahlkampf geführt wir haben
uns sehr bemüht auch landespolitische
Themen nach vorne zu bringen wir haben
Wirtschaft die Bildung in Hessen und
auch die Bürokratie in den Mittelpunkt
gestellt wir hatten konkrete Vorstellung
auch zum Thema wie gehen wir mit der
Migration in Hessen um wie gehen wir mit
der Flüchtlingsfrage um gerade auch in
der
Erstaufnahme in gieen wir haben ja auch
sehr stark
die Sachleistungen die Geldkarte
gegenüber der ähm der
der des Bargeldes und
ja das Bargeldes ja herausgehoben und
uns da auch glaube ich in Namen gemacht
an der Stelle und äh wir sind aber nicht
immer mit landespolitischen Themen
durchgedrungen weil die Union es sehr
leicht hatte natürlich vor allem auch
mit bundespolitischen Stimmung hier zu
punkten insofern ähm haben wir hier
unser Wahlziel nicht erreicht dann
herzlichen Dank wir kommen jetzt zu
ihren Fragen als erstes Herr fehweger
bitte ja guten Morgen es gibt einen Satz
der heißt lieber ein Ende mit Schrecken
als ein Schrecken ohne Ende ist ihn
schon mal der G Gedanke kommmen Herr
Lindner diese Regierung diese
Ampelkoalition zu beenden die FDP ist
eine staatstragende Partei
wir setzen unsere inhaltlichen Akzente
ja auch hier in Berlin in der
Koalition weit mehr als unser
politisches Gewicht es eigentlich hätte
erwarten lassen prägen wir auch
Regierungshandeln insgesamt muss man
allerdings feststellen dass die
Koalition den Erwartungen der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger nicht entspricht
in den Bereichen Wirtschaft
Migration Klima und Energiepolitik und
Frage der gesellschaftlichen Liberalität
und das bezieht ja auch die Freiheit der
Lebensführung die Wahlfreiheit ein
gibt's
offensichtlich Kritikpunkte solcher Art
dar dass auch SPD und Grüne
Unterstützung verlieren und das müssen
wir gemeinsam miteinander
aufarbeiten als nächstes Frau Rossbach
bitte ja herzlichen Dank ihr general
Sekretär hatte gestern auch gesagt dass
die entscheidenden Themen angegangen
werden müssen er nannte eben auch
Migration und die wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung und sagte dann in dem
Nachsatz oder falls wir über oder sehen
ob wir überhaupt zu Lösungen kommen
können bei diesen Themen wie haben Sie
ihn da verstanden das klang so ein
bisschen nach wenn wir keine Lösung
finden dann war's das mit der Ampel oder
interpretiere ich dazu viel hinein ich
äh weiß nicht was genau der Wortlaut war
und wo er das gesagt hat ich habe nur
das Pressestatement hier ähm gesehen was
also nicht auf was sie sich da beziehen
aber für uns ist klar es geht um eine
kritische
Reflektion unseres
Regierungshandelns jetzt nach dem
Wahltag geht es darum zur Halbzeit zu
schauen was ist erreicht was nehmen wir
uns weiter vor äh und welche
Anforderungen aus der Sache ergibt es
ergbt es für uns wir haben immer noch zu
hohe Inflation wir haben Rezession und
darauf muss ja reagiert werden wir haben
äh sehr hohe Zahlen äh im Bereich der
Migration wir haben immer noch nicht
abschließend unterbunden dass es
illegale Einwanderung in unser Land gibt
gibt ganz klares Signal der Wählerinnen
und Wähler dass sie sich hier
Fortschritte wünschen und da müssen wir
unsere gemeinsame Handlungsfähigkeit
jetzt herstellen und zu Konsequenzen in
der Sache
finden die nächste Frage kommt von Herrn
Busch
bitte Herr Lindner sie haben ja gesagt
die Koalition muss ihre Arbeit kritisch
reflektieren ähm in welchem Format
sollte das Ding geschehen wäre das ein
Fall für den
Koalitionsausschuss und vielleicht in
Verbindung damit wie intensiv sind denn
ihre Kontakte zu den anderen
Parteivorsitzenden in der Ampel
also das Format des
Koalitionsausschusses ist sicherlich
auch geeignet für so ein vertieftes
Gespräch macht ohnehin Sinn weil wir
jetzt ja im November Dezember so die
Halbzeit haben 2 Jahre nach Abschluss
des
Koalitionsvertrages und am 20 Oktober
ist ja auch passt ja gut schon seit
einigen Wochen einen Koalitionsausschuss
geplant und das kann dann ein erstes ich
sage ausdrücklich D abschließendes nicht
dass jetzt schon sofort im Kalender
anstreichen und sagen oh das da jetzt in
dem Umfeld 2010 wird jetzt aber was ganz
Großes passieren das wird aber eine
erste Gelegenheit sein sich darüber im
Kreis
auszutauschen zu den Parteivorsitzenden
der beiden anderen Koalitionsparteien
habe ich natürlich
eng und sehr regelmäßigen
Austausch die nächste Frage von Frau
Bucholz
bitte muss denn die FDP jetzt auch
innerhalb der Ampel anders auftreten
also haben sie da irgendwie ein Konzept
wie man sich jetzt mehr profiliert oder
anders profiliert nein wir orientieren
uns strikt an Positionen und Inhalten
und es geht uns um die sachliche Klärung
von Fragen die unser Land voranbringen
und daran halten wir fest
als nächstes Herrn weiland
bitte ja Herr Lindner guten Morgen zwei
Fragen wenn Sie erlauben erste welchen
Anteil haben Sie denn an den
durchwachsenen bis schlechten
Ergebnissen bei den Landtagswahlen haben
sie sich das selber mal gefragt habe ich
vielleicht was falsch gemacht muss ich
da einen anderen inhaltlichen Akzent
oder Kurs setzen und das zweite würde
mich interessieren Herr schffler hat
davon gesprochen gestern dass die Ampel
wie ein ein Mühlstein an der FDP Hänge
der die FDP immer weiter herunterziehe
sehen Sie das auch so die Parteien der
Ampel werden das ist ja auch ein ein
eine Lehre oder eine Einsicht der
letzten Wahlen und auch des gestrigen
wahlsonntags sie werden nicht
individuell bewertet sondern die Ampel
als ganze wird von den Menschen
beurteilt deshalb haben alle die
Regierung tragenden drei Parteien ja
Einbußen zielt und auch wenn die FDP
anders nuanciert und andere politische
Positionen vertritt also gerade in den
wahlentscheidenden Fragen Wirtschaft
Eindämmung der Migration Klimaschutz mit
Augenmaß und Freiheit nanieren wir
anders als unsere Koalitionspartner wir
werden aber trotzdem als Teil der Ampel
von den Wählerinnen und Wählern
beurteilt und deshalb ist meine
Konsequenz daraus die Koalition
insgesamt muss ihre Arbeit reflektieren
damit wir insgesamt erfolgreich werden
und mein Anteil daran ist der wie der
von allen anderen
groß